how are you guys doing
very good yeah very well uh I really
want to say sincere thank you for coming
in today and also congratulations for
being at Comic-Con in Hall h and and and
exposing more of the world to what you
guys are doing and uh you know the movie
you're making
um so I just have to ask in India is
Comic-Con something that like people
know about and talk about or is it uh
more an American thing
well I would say like my daughter had
the Next Generation does know about
Comic-Con but uh generally speaking
after this they will know because
everybody is talking about it for sure I
think like the smaller towns and
everything this movie would reach there
so everyone's asking what is this
Comic-Con where are these guys go
smaller smaller towns they're not aware
but it's it's a good exposure for
this kind of a collaboration sure I have
to ask you because one of the things
about Comic-Con is that everyone here
likes to geek out over things whether it
be posters or Collectibles or movies or
TV whatever it is very passionate fans
so what can I ask is there anything that
you're really passionate about in terms
of like do you collect something or if
you get to walk the convention floor
would you be looking for a certain
poster or comic book
Collectibles are yet to happen in India
in a big way but uh I am a cinema buff
so for me for all posters are a very big
thing I have a
a little library of things which I had
not enough walls to put it up so I keep
changing the posters I'm very fond of
posters
so I collect them you if you manage to
walk the floor you will see a lot of
them and you might actually want to take
something home
yeah it looks beautiful on the floor the
number of hoodies and merchandise and
collectibles I always kept insisting to
my producers that we should do
merchandising because people do like to
take
things back even in weddings when they
go they take back
this is like
I think they're giving out
so that's we should show it to the
camera
it's like sort of thing and that's what
he's there okay and yeah
so this for you actually you can keep it
oh my God thank you so it's just
something you can just keep on your desk
and you'll remember oh I'm 100 keeping
this that's great uh thank you uh it's
like a like a collectible coin or pretty
much yeah yeah so the the reason I get
to talk to you guys is you're obviously
promoting your movie here at Comic-Con
um and I'm just curious what can you
actually tell fans about it what do you
want people to know
well just what is there in the teaser
actually it's just a small glimpse it's
not even the story story because we
still have about six months before the
film comes out
and uh but it's a very new world for us
in India because we've not done
something in the Sci-Fi space so like
all the images and all the vehicles and
the character looks
just the wideness of that world they'll
be very curious to see how it is but not
the story so whatever's then the teaser
we'd be sharing but one of the things I
did a lot of research before you guys
came in and listen sci-fi is probably my
favorite genre and I'm very excited to
see what you guys are cooking together
because I know
um the thing that I found fascinating
and tell me if I'm wrong is that what
you'll do when you're filming is you'll
shoot for like eight nine days and then
take a break to get things together and
then shoot more or am I wrong about this
it depends
if it's a complicated uh technical issue
we might have to drink the take that
break for logistical reasons otherwise I
come from an industry called Malayalam
film Industries A Small industry so it
is one long distance run
beginning to end we have to finish
shooting in three weeks
movies yeah like 22 days they finished
like a full feature 22 days
23 days max and we'll have to finish the
film so everybody is geared for that so
so it sometimes exceeds 12 hours of work
yeah nowadays I think it is taking yeah
now longer like now it's taking longer
but I come from that school totally yeah
so uh we have a
larger lungs
so you'll run for longer well but I read
that you guys were um you you were
building uh vehicles and you're building
things you're you're creating a new
essentially a new world so what can you
sort of say about that and because I
find that fascinating and I'm very
interested in new worlds and new I you
know what I mean
yeah I mean it's uh it's very exciting
for me to be able because I love sci-fi
and I love even uh all of the Star Wars
I grew up with Star Wars a lot so and I
love Indian mythology we grew up with
Mahabharata and a lot of stories from
our mythology and these two loves
uh I didn't know I always felt it would
be great if he could put them together
somehow and and somehow the story
happened and because there was something
in the story it the actors happened and
now we're here talking to you and and uh
it's yeah we're building this whole new
world which is very original because
it's Indian in a Sci-Fi space so it'll
be it's the first experiment I hope yeah
we did a we did Justice listen I'm all
in on this I'm really looking forward to
seeing it one of the things that I'm so
curious about is were there any films
besides Star Wars like did you look at a
blade runner for example in the spinner
in Blade Runner and say I like that but
I want to do this
yeah I uh
uh I mean Blade Runner I think I
discovered more recently but even Total
Recall was one of our favorite sci-fi
for me uh it started with
even Android's Dream of Electric Sheep
yeah the book
so I like that kind of Science Fiction
where it's
you're able to correlate with your own
thoughts of what future would be
so I like that and what he is attempting
to do is why the reason why I'm happily
part of this project is that we have a
great mythological thread running
through for thousands of years so if you
hit the correct symbols people will
understand the storyline and which
direction it's going
they have iconic characters in
Mahabharata ramayan and you just have to
give a hint of it and they'll almost
know
what would be the next scene so you can
cut to the chase quickly can I ask you
what can you tease about the character
you're playing
that he has to say
that I don't know how much to reveal I
know too much right I think you probably
do what what can you tease
I think
everyone's waiting to see sir in this
role and what what it's going to be like
in this film and why he agreed to do it
and why we wanted sir to do it so I
think
I'd like to leave the surprise sure I I
listen my job and people know that about
me is I'm always digging as far as I can
without getting to spoilers I'm always
looking for what can you tease you know
what I mean
um well let me ask you this uh I read
and again please correct me if I'm wrong
but as you're filming you're filming in
two different languages or am I wrong
about this
I mean not not all the scenes actually
but we started off doing it uh
in a way that we know that some scenes
are definitely going to be more
impactful if we also shoot it in Hindi
so we are shooting in two languages but
for the most part it's a Telugu film
and uh it's a country with five strong
Industries
with a large demography of audience so
it will be wiser to reach out to all of
them
it's like
you have a single language called
English which could cross-continence but
within a subcontinent called India we
have 22 languages
so it's quite a complicated
communication process
so believe me I I know I've heard all
about it I'm curious what is it like in
I'm going to ask you this question I
know you're rather well known in India
what is it like for you to be here in
America and at Comic-Con can you be a
little Anonymous or is it still you're
screwed no if if it depends on uh the
people if there are many Indians they'll
recognize me
but the all-americans and I'm happy to
be one among the crowd and be a cinema
buffer and
collector like everybody else sure what
is it like in India right now with you
guys making this movie because it is one
of the biggest uh budgeted India
produced movies that's ever been done so
do you find that there is an awful lot
of interest in the film while you're
filming
yeah for sure because uh
I mean I think definitely one of the
biggest reasons is the starcast also
because they don't know what the film is
about they just know that it's an
attempted sci-fi and it has four of the
biggest stars who have agreed on the
script so they're very curious
definitely and we've released a couple
of posters that just teases the tone of
the film but it's just like hands like
so it's not much uh but still people are
very excited just looking at that well
what's interesting is and I don't know
if you know this but Studio Ghibli just
released their movie Miyazaki released
his new movie in Japan and on opening
day they had not released a trailer any
images anything just it's the new
Miyazaki movie and people went in not
knowing anything and I found that
amazing because so many trailers give
away so much so are you thinking about
already like how much do we want to hold
back when the marketing does begin you
know what I mean
I think we also are in a place where
people want to know what they're getting
into like especially in the bigger
like commercial space like when you make
big budget budgeted films like you want
a bigger audience to know exactly what
they're coming for so that's why the
trailers are sort of they tell you a lot
sure yeah so I mean I I think that works
uh for movies like this
there are quite a few big names
in in the film
but uh all big names I have the humility
to understand it's not the brand but
it's the content that's going to work
so we are all looking forward to that
and about my participation nobody
believed that I have a part of this
project as a matter of fact yesterday
there's a funny thing is the product
news of this film Mr prabhas just held
my hand and said thank you I said what I
wouldn't believe it till today that
you're part of it because I'm still
wondering
how they got you in well but I am
curious you wrote the script and when
you were writing were you thinking about
certain actors as you wrote Because in
America generally all the writers I
speak to say you never try to think of
someone in a role because you'll just
get disappointed when they say no
foreign
but also but also I I had like a image
of the characters and only after I
finished a few drafts did I start
imagining people in the role uh but yeah
that's about the best way to go because
a character looms larger than an actor
and then the actor fits in
and it doesn't matter if one says no
there'll always be another I'm a writer
also apart from being sure so I I take
pride in creating rather than be part of
just a big canvas
do you guys Envision this could be the
start of because in America one of the
things when they make big budget movies
is they're always thinking about how can
we do a spin-off or what's the sequel
they're thinking long term because of
the investment and I'm curious with this
were you thinking about this as just a a
single story or do you think this is
something that could you know Branch
into sequels or other media
well I definitely started wanting to
create the world so uh like whether it's
maybe more than sequels it's also just
the
the characters in the film The locations
or the vehicles that we create I always
thought like we could make like an
animated shot of that we could have like
cars or trucks from our designs could
have figures and I thought that kind of
world this movie allows so yeah
yeah but spin-offs and all it's just
only this movie right now that I'm
thinking about
this is my last thing for you because
you need to go promote your movie at
Comic-Con what do you think would
surprise people to learn about making
movies in India that maybe they wouldn't
know in America
from what I can say we started off as a
very small industry in the sense we were
making the largest number of films in
the world yet we were not geared we
didn't have the grouted
framework to do all that but we managed
so I think
the greatest quality that I find after
having worked a bit with the Hollywood
technicians that Indians are great
chaos managers
they thrive in chaos and bring a
coagulate a film together which is
fantastic and some of my American
technicians were astounded by it and
they're too scared to be imitated
because so much money is at stake here
there are certain things that even our
Hollywood does where you come and
improvise
on the set certain things which have
been planned for months together and you
make that the last minute tweak even Mr
Spielberg had done that in Temple of
Doom
where there was a big fight sequence and
the protagonist the hero of the film was
unwell and he he was so tired he said
why do I have to fight he pulled out a
gun and shot and
it's a speed bug it seems cocked Us in
and said do it and we'll wrap it with
today into the four days of shooting
that's a on the spot decision that's
what India is very very capable of doing
and most of the best sequences and films
have happened on the set sometimes
whether it's a collaboration of
technicians directors but it's teetering
on the edge things could go wrong so it
is rope walking that that's why probably
when you have bigger Investments you'll
have to plan harder no for sure um I'm
gonna stop you there because I know you
have to go to your panel and I can feel
the evil eyes so I'm just going to say
I'm really looking forward to seeing the
final film and I hope to talk to you
again once I've seen it have a fantastic
on thank you